I don't think that we can uninvent
nuclear weapons I think that we can get
to a situation where the United States
and Soviet Union have dismantled all but
a few hundred of their nuclear weapons
each which would mean that a number of
powers had only a couple of hundred
total each and that would be the limit I
think that that would be a very positive
step I don't think it's worth talking
about grand proposals for abolition
unless we can get to that point and have
the political will internationally to
get to that point it makes for a great
in provocative a bed or a series of op
eds as Kissinger & Co have done but it's
not realistic until we can at least get
to the stage that we were supposed to be
at right now under arms control
agreements that were signed in the 1990s
but have more or less been ignored in
the last eight years